simone im viertel mögen mich alle
das ist mir wichtig logan bailly von
matteo gar ohne ist kein schöner film
dann würde es nicht sein und er soll es
auch nicht sein
laut man spielt in einer gegend die wir
meistens im kino kennen
auf der rückseite süditalien auf der
schattenseite der landschaftlichen
schönheit kampaniens dir ja ziemlich
verfallene ladenstraße betreibt der
hundefriseur marcello sein geschäft und
von hier aus versorgt er seine frau
simone einen deutlichen kleinkriminellen
und schläger mit dem von ihm benötigten
kokain
hast du das kleine tochter ist diese
zwangsgemeinschaft die von den brutalen
simone dominiert wird zerbricht als
marcello seinem freund seinen laden für
einen einbruch ins benachbarte
juweliergeschäft zur verfügung gestellt
musst du bei so vielen goldhändlern die
es gibt ausgerechnet bei meinem freund
franco einbrechen
warum gelten wahl gestellt simone zu
verraten oder ins gefängnis zu gehen
entscheidet sich marcello des
zuchthauses ja zurückkehrt sagt er
seinen anteil an dem diebesgut anteil
etwa 1000 euro
ich habe keine 10.000 euro manche diesen
kontakt zur italienischen realität der
bis dahin immer noch gehalten hat und
verliert sich in der melodramatik einer
gangster und freundschaftsgeschichte
jetzt auf brutale weise im gleis
[Applaus]
ohne die stars von gomorrha eine
verfilmung des bestsellerromans von
roberto saviano die bis heute der
wahrscheinlich beste film spielfilm
beitrag zur lage der mafia in süditalien
zur realität der welt die von der kamera
bestimmt wird darstellt in diesem
älteren filmen vor zehn jahren hat er
holte fünf verschiedene geschichten
parallel erzählt und zu einem bruch
eines unfalls zusammenhangs
verflochtenen betretet das an
glaubwürdigkeit die nicht überwiegend
gerade in seinen neuen film konzentriert
sich auf eine geschichte dieser film
sieht sehr gut aus setzen all seiner
furchtbaren dringlichkeit sehr schön
anzusehen wenn ich aber es fehlt ihm
etwas was der filmkamera hatte
realitätsbezug
man könnte sagen markierung würde war
schon einmal weiter aber es hilft ja
nichts
das kino geht auch immer weiter jetzt
gibt es diesen film und nur von ihnen
können wir hier sprechen
ich kann dort man leider nur
eingeschränkt empfehlen
sehenswert für diejenigen die wissen
möchten wie es heute in italien aussieht
hinter den kulissen ist der denn
[Musik]